so I wanted to build on something that
we we talked about yesterday and that is
if you if you remember we we talked
about social media and how social media
fuels our narcissism and causes us to
think about ourselves focus on ourselves
an inordinate amount and this is where a
lot of the self-esteem issues come from
now it's not that we it's not that we we
think badly about ourselves in this
culture it's that it's just that we
think about ourselves way too often we
spend way too much time thinking about
ourselves and when we do that of course
we're gonna notice our flaws and of
course we're gonna be obsessed with
those flaws because we're obsessed with
ourselves and then we and then we we
chalk that up to a self-esteem problem
when really it's a it's a it's a
narcissism problem it's almost the
opposite of a self-esteem problem and
now that isn't to say that we should
never notice our flaws we have to be we
need to be self-aware we need to know
that we have flaws but we shouldn't
spend all day noticing them and the best
thing to do with a character flaw or a
moral flaw is to once you notice it -
then just set out to correct it - live
your life and try to correct it in the
way that you live your life and the best
thing to do with a with an unfixable
physical flaw is to just forget it and
again live your life
either way the process is harder and we
are interfering with it when we are too
focused on ourselves now I mentioned
that I think these these love yourself
embrace your flaws types of campaigns
are misguided and they're very common
these days of course where we're
constantly being told to love yourself
love yourself I think it's misguided
because we should be encouraging each
other to to forget about ourselves
forget yourself
and focus on other things look outward
instead of always inward
so I don't agree with running around and
telling everyone to love themselves and
in fact I think that if we just dropped
that phrase from our vocabulary
completely and never again discussed
loving yourself self-love you got to
love if we never talked about those
things ever again we would be better for
it
now I got a lot of feedback to that idea
about self-love so some of it positive a
lot of it negative or critical I should
say anyway and and honestly the critical
feedback it hurt my own self-love so I
want you to know that hurt my feelings
so now I wanted to order to expand the
planet a little bit more because I think
it's an important point
my basic theory is this loving yourself
if understood correctly can be good but
not as an end in itself and not as the
beginning either
now I think there are two huge mistakes
we make when we talk about self love the
idea of loving ourselves are two huge
mistakes
the first mistake is in thinking that
loving yourself is the highest good and
the ultimate point of life that's
obviously a big mistake
the second mistake is in thinking that
self love is the starting point and you
really can't love anyone else until you
love yourself now I'm not gonna spend
much time debunking the first idea which
is which is Satanism the idea that self
love is the highest code the ultimate
point that's Satanism and it is a
philosophy that's been adopted in the
mainstream by by by leftism but I've
talked about that plenty of times in the
past I will again in the future for now
I I'm gonna address the second idea
which is prevalent even among people who
know that self love is not the highest
good it's still very prevalent and you
hear this all the time don't you rate me
you've heard this meant maybe you've
said it yourself that you can't love
someone else until you learn to love
yourself you'll even hear that that you
really can't do anything with your life
until you love yourself this is what's
implied when you ask someone you know
you meet someone that you haven't seen
in a while and you say oh what are you
doing with yourself what are you doing
for a living and they say well I'm just
working on myself right now just working
on myself now Christians will tend to
think that and what he means is he's
completely he is this is a person who
has just caved in on themselves just
completely just there you're looking at
a void of a person where they have
completely caved in and they've blocked
everything else out and they're just
thinking about themselves all day and
we're working on themselves
now Christians will tend to think that
scriptural support for this approach
they'll point to Jesus saying love your
neighbor as yourself and they take that
to mean that you cannot begin the
project of loving your neighbor until
you have developed a sufficient
affection for yourself but that is not
at all what is meant
you see we have to remember that love
your neighbor as yourself is the second
greatest commandment first commandment
that we're given is love the Lord God
with all your with all your heart and
with all your soul and with all your
mind and with all your strength
um I would say that if we if we
concentrate on the first commandment
which is loving God and then if we
concentrate next on the first part of
the second commandment which is loving
our neighbor and if we really give that
our attention then love for ourselves
we'll just be tossed into the bargain we
don't even have to think about it
if you're really focused on loving God
and loving your neighbor then then your
self-love just comes with it it's just
part of it
self-love is not the starting point it's
not the beginning and it's not the end
goal either it's a byproduct it's
something that happens in the middle and
not because you're trying to make it
happen it it simply does happen there's
another important thing we should
remember about love your neighbor as
yourself love your neighbor as yourself
what that really means in context is
keep your neighbors interests at heart
like you keep your own interests at
heart
this is not this is Jesus is not
recommending self-esteem that Jesus is
simply building off of the fact that we
all naturally as individuals value our
own interests and work towards
fulfilling them everybody on earth
naturally does that now we may have very
wrong ideas about what's in our best
interest but we still are that's we were
very concerned about that all the time
we're concerned about our own interest
so Jesus is just taking that for granted
he's not saying to work on that or to
build that up he's saying you're already
like that so you don't to think about
that's how you are but instead take that
mentality and apply it to your neighbor
don't worry about fortifying that
mentality about yourself apply it to
your neighbor
but we've taken this command and we've
done the opposite we've taken it the
opposite direction that's the opposite
of what we were supposed to do when we
use it as an excuse for selfishness no
no no that's that's the opposite of what
he meant I think there are two things
about love that we have to remember in
order to tie you know in order to really
work through this idea of self-love
the first thing is you know Aquinas says
that to love he defines love as willing
the good of the other right that is
wanting what is good for someone not
necessarily wanting them to always get
what they want but wanting what is
actually good for them what is actually
good and then working so far as we can
to actively bring about that good
I've never heard a better definition of
love that I think that is that's the
definition it's it right that's yeah
whatever the dictionary says that right
there Aquinas he has the definition to
will the good of the other at least
that's the definition for person to
person love love for God is a little bit
different because you can't really will
the good of God he are he already has
everything he needs
there is no good that you can provide
for him or wish for him because he's the
author of all good so he already has all
that he contains it he is it love for
God I think could be defined more like
maybe something like what wanting to
give God what he is do which would be
our faith our loyalty our trust our
obedience so a loving God means but how
does this definition apply to self love
what does it even mean to love yourself
what is what is the definition
and it's kind of confusing because
you'll notice that both of these
definitions although the second one I
just came up with but the the first one
from Thomas qty that it's outwardly
focused by definition how do you bring
it back on yourself
well I guess
to love yourself if if loving others is
to will the good of the other to love
yourself must mean to will what is good
for you not to will what is pleasurable
necessarily or even what is always
desirable but to will what is actually
edifying healthy wholesome things that
are going to elevate you bring you
closer to truth and to beauty and to God
to love someone else to put it more
simply is to want them to go to heaven
and to work to kind of help them get
there and so to love yourself is to want
yourself to go to heaven and to help
yourself get there but that desire in
its in its fullest and holiest state is
not rooted in a love for yourself it's
rooted in a love for God so you you want
to be good and do good because that's
what you ought to do because that's what
God deserves for you to do
so I think we see that self-love cannot
be the starting point
can't be the point at all it's not the
point it's a thing that happens when you
worry about loving things beyond
yourself
it is the product of those things second
point we see from Aquinas is definition
that love is active it's not just a
feeling
this of course is a is a huge
misconception we have in our culture and
it's been disastrous for our culture
it's been disastrous especially for
families and for marriages where we look
at love as a feeling of affection but
it's not love is an act - will - will
the good of the other problem is that
when people talk about about loving
themselves they mean it almost always as
a purely emotional exercise they mean
they mean to say that they want to feel
good about themselves that's what this
so that's what they mean so I'm working
on loving myself what they mean is I'm
working on feeling good about myself
there they are essentially sitting
around trying to conjure up emotions
about themselves
or maybe they're even taking drugs the
to help that or whatever there there
there they are trying to develop
emotions in their head about themselves
and this is a ridiculous exercise
because you're never gonna reach a state
where you feel always good about
yourself that's never gonna happen
it shouldn't happen anyway
you should there are times when you
should feel bad about yourself
when you do something bad when you do a
horrible or selfish or cowardly thing
you should feel bad about yourself you
shouldn't feel great in those moments it
doesn't mean you should hate yourself
you shouldn't go into despondency and
despair over it but but you shouldn't
feel good about yourself either
um
so there's never going to be there's
never going to be a point where you
always joking about subject just like
just like you you're never gonna reach a
point where you feel always affectionate
towards your your spouse or your kids
but you love your spouse and your kids
hopefully anyway in fact in fact love
really comes into play in the moments
where you don't feel particularly good
you're talking about you're in a family
setting with your with your spouse and
your children
it's when you don't feel that really
strong affection because you're tired or
you're annoyed or you're angry or you're
hurt or whatever it is right it's when
you don't feel that when you when you
when you don't have that affection
necessarily that's when love really
comes in that's when the love is really
needed because then to love the other
person is an act of will it's really a
choice it's not just something that
you're doing because because you happen
to be feeling pretty good at the moment
anybody can act loving when they feel
loving anyone could do that doesn't mean
anything even the most abusive and
horrible spouse can still act loving in
the moments where he feels loving
doesn't mean anything if the moment when
those those feelings leave you start
acting like a tyrant
so to act loving when you don't feel it
that's the real thing right there I mean
that's that's it that's love it's that's
really love and it's in its strongest
state
or maybe I should say in its rawest
state so when we always focus on our
emotions about ourselves we're embarking
on this really foolish and narcissistic
quest to reach a state of emotional
constancy in relation to ourselves which
is never going to happen instead we
should just be always doing what is good
for ourselves actually good
not what is always pleasurable or
anything like that but just what is
actually good what is actually bringing
us higher and closer to truth and and we
should just be doing that all the time
and let the emotions come and go as they
will
so that there really shouldn't be a
reason to talk about self-love it's not
the point of everything it's not the
starting point it's not the end it's not
something you feel it's it's something
that comes with the package of loving
others in a real and active way last
thing I'll say is this think about the
implications of this idea that that you
have to love yourself before you can
love other people
think about what that looks like in
practice think about how this must work
in a marriage for the brief period where
somebody with this mentality could
actually stay at a marriage think about
how that must work
you'd be going up to your spouse and
saying sorry honey I can't love you
today
I'm just not feeling great about myself
you see I need to love myself again and
then oh and then I'll get around to you
okay but I can't love you right now
because I'm just not feeling great
that obviously is not the right approach
the opposite is is the better approach
forget about yourself love your spouse
serve your spouse and then magically
you'll find that your opinion of
yourself improves
it's if that's what happens
it's really it's really magical like
that go out and do good things for
others
and do your duty fulfill your
responsibilities live as though you feel
great about yourself and then you'll
find that oh wow I feel pretty good
right now
but then you can't but but here's what
I'm talking about we've become so
focused on our emotions about ourselves
you can't that's your emotions about
yourself that's that's just an
underlying thing it's it's it's a
current that's kind of there but you
can't stop and think about it because
even when you're going out and you're
living your life and you're doing what
you're supposed to do and you're being
self sacrificial and you're being loving
towards others that is gonna lift you up
emotionally as well but the moment that
you stop and dwell on it you stop think
wow I really feel great about myself
right now let me think more about how I
feel about myself let me analyze the the
moment you do that it all falls apart
you start losing all of it it's like now
it's now it's just water through your
fingertips and you're trying to grab it
it's like no I just had it it's gone now
that's because you're not supposed to
stop and think about it continue living
continue going it I guess it's it's a
little bit like when you if you've ever
really dwelled on breathing
or if you've been walking and you and
you began to think this is kind of a how
am i walking right now I'm not I don't
feel myself telling myself to what you
start dwelling on the act of walking or
the act in the moment you do that it
starts to feel weird like you almost
forget how to do it
because you're not supposed to dwell on
it
it's kind of something that your your
you do automatically
so love yourself first and then and then
you can love others no I think I think I
think the opposite is the case I think
maybe the way that we should phrase it
is is is something like this you cannot
love yourself
until you learn how to love something
other than yourself
I think maybe that's the way we should
put it
and that's how we should live alright
thanks for watching and thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed